Now, before dug deeper into the more sophisticated algorithms,
I would like to briefly tell you a little about a technique known as brute force.
So what does brute force mean? Does it mean that we take a hammer
and beat the answer out of our computer?
Of course not. Brute force is the algorithm that Alice, Bob, and Carol were using initially.
So, you remember, for example, that for Bob,
we were using an algorithm like this or not using but proposing an algorithm like this at least
that simply went through all possible assignments of zero and one to the vertices,
or at that time, we steal common genes and weakness of this algorithm was that
it had a pretty unacceptable running time
as soon as you got to more than 20 or 30 vertices in the network.
But this algorithm actually also has two strength.
One strength from it is that it's very simple, and the other thing is that,
because it's so simple, you can actually also implement it rather fast.
Under certain conditions, using an algorithm like this,
actually might not be that bad an idea
in this method of using all possible assignments.
First of all, we're not confused the hammer here.
This method if going through all possible assignments without any more sophisticated
techniques or sophisticated algorithmic techniques is known as brute force.
And so, as I've explained to you, there are certain conditions for brute force is actually desirable.
So, let's have you figure out what those conditions could be,
and by brute force, of course, we try all possibilities.
Could it be that when you don't have much time to design and program a more sophisticated algorithm.
Could it be when the instances where the inputs for which you're trying to solve your problem are small.
Say n is the size of the problem smaller than 20
or could it be when you need to solve the problem only once
and the input might be a little bit bigger there.
For each one, I'm going to give you two choices
whether under these conditions using brute force could be okay
and the first one is a maybe and second one is a definitive no.
I'm not going to give you a clear yes choice because,
obviously, since we're dealing with NP complete problems here,
brute force is never generally advisable of course.